[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
the Stanley Cup
[Applause]
Bill Foley had the vision the creativity
and the audacity to bring the first
major league team to Las Vegas
and then he said we're going to win the
Stanley Cup in six years
what has happened here has been simply
incredible not only
is Vegas a hockey town it's a
championship town
congratulations to George McPhee Kelly
McCrimmon Bruce Cassidy and most
important the players on your Vegas
golden knights
Mark Stone our tradition for this 130
year old trophy it's the presented to
the captain
all right
[Applause]
Mark stone hands it off to the original
Vegas goal tonight Riley Smith
[Applause]
count Smythe winner is going to get it
next
as Marsha so hands it off to another
original Vegas golden Knight William
Carlson
we welcome in the great one our teammate
Wayne Gretzky who was presented to
Stanley Cup on four different occasions
Wayne described the feeling well as an
athlete as a hockey player there's no
better feeling than the first time you
get to lift the Stanley Cup and as
you're skating around with the trophy
obviously your teammates are a huge part
of that the coaches the fans in the city
and then you think about your
grandparents and maybe the odd uncle or
minor league coaches that helped you get
there and those are the thoughts that go
through your mind that they all are a
big part of you lifting that Stanley Cup
2023 Stanley Cup Final
well I was just so impressed by both
teams I thought both coaches did an
amazing job both organizations deserve a
lot of credit
Florida played their hearts out they
just happened to run up against the team
that was a little bit bigger a little
bit faster had a lot of depth and their
goalie ended up playing extremely well
they should keep their heads high they
played against the machine in the
Stanley Cup finals and they lost to a
really good Hockey Club
[Applause]
on air and off here how well Vegas
defended the importance of being able to
play without the pumpkin
pen but don't break at times yeah just
the importance of playing that way and
eventually winning like you did so many
times a year let me tell you something
there's no nothing more fun than scoring
goals in the National Hockey League we
all love to score goals but I said it
last year I'll save this year defense
wins Stanley Cups when our team learned
in Edmonton how to play defense we
became Stanley Cup champions Aiko was a
machine back there for an offensive
player he was always in the right
position the right spot and he was their
offensive guy that led with a two-way
game and that just trickles through the
whole Hockey Club they deserve all the
credit they're getting they they didn't
take a lot of penalties they killed them
when they had to defensively they were
strong they didn't give up a lot of
two-on-ones ultimately it became Stanley
Cup champions Wayne you watch Stanley
Cups with an all-time great goaltender
and Grant Fjord as Jack Eiffel was
having a cup from Chandler Stevenson
we saw the photos owner of the series he
attended your hockey school
and now he's a Stanley Cup champion well
we can say now that we put through a
Stanley Cup champion through our hockey
schools right but you know what uh
people in this game are so wonderful
he's a great example he worked his tail
off he didn't give up he was fifth
goalie I know we talked a lot about this
he was the fifth goalie on the list and
he won a Stanley Cup and listen they
could have picked one of four or five
different guys to win the cons Smite and
he was in that mix no question how do
you probably played in the first round
he might even had a better chance than
anybody but listen good for him what a
great story and like I said we finally
got a
gun they went through our hockey score
and won a Stanley Cup but listen I
wanted to say to Jonesy good luck to you
man we're all going to miss you and we
know you're gonna do a great job in
Philadelphia and I know Mr Snyder's
looking down and he knows he got the
right guy to do that job good luck to
you Jonesy
he certainly will thanks Wayne we'll
look forward to hearing from you in the
gag during the post game it's been great
spending the last couple of weeks with
you all right guys thank you
well thank you very much Mark what did
it feel like when you were handed the
Stanley Cup by the commissioner
unbelievable
just looked in my teammates eyes when I
got it
one of the craziest feelings I've ever
had
um
that's another idea with a 25 30 best
friends
um makes it that much more special when
you're a kid growing up did it match the
feelings you dreamed about yeah
can't even describe the feelings in my
like right now it's
[Applause]
it's the groin of an 82 Game season four
playoff rounds you're grinding you're
grinding you're grinding at the end of
the day the last team standing it's
incredible and not making the playoffs
last year and doing what you did this
year what can you say about your head
coach Bruce Cassidy I mean he came in
brought an intensity to our locker room
that maybe we needed um
and I think he he wanted to win just as
bad as everybody else in that Locker in
my even see the emotion in his face
right now
um
I don't know what else to say at all
everybody that's in those four walls
it's amazing go celebrate with your
teammates congratulations thank you
mayor
[Applause]
backside out to Jackie with the conspire
Trophy winner Jonathan marshasso
Jonathan
an original six
The Vibes are a lot different now than
they were in 2018. yeah it was uh we
waited a long time for that moment to
come back and uh we want to make sure
that we uh we cash in our time and I
couldn't be more proud of
our team our organization we've grind in
for a few years and uh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an 18. so now winning it all and
achieving a lifelong dream
you know what that's the pain that you
you can describe too and that's the
feeling that we have right now it's hard
to describe I mean that pain was it was
tough to be honest it took me almost a
couple of months a full year to get over
it and uh because they're so close but
so far and I mean that time around I I
just took a different approach and look
where we are right now her team has been
unbelievable since the beginning and uh
we're we're winners
[Applause]
season either tied the game or gave
Vegas the lead what is it about you that
makes you shine when the spotlight is
the biggest uh it's one of those things
that I just uh you know one night is one
guy and one night that's another guy
that's that's the mentality we had this
year just next minute and has to do the
job and we're a bunch of good teammates
in our locker room and uh we're always
happy for each other and honestly
everybody stepped up at different times
and that's where today we're winners
[Applause]
[Music]
what a postseason for Jonathan marshasso
and let's not forget the guy that got it
was the clue on that line Kenny with
Jack Keitel and Jonathan Marsha so but
Ivan Barbershop late season acquisition
by general manager Kelly mcrimmon along
with Georgia McPhee bringing him in
there were eight or ten teams that were
all over
Ivan Barbershop
[Applause]
I'm so close in Boston
losing in game seven of the St Louis
Blues
Kelly McCrimmon Bill Foley George McPhee
the general manager Kelly mcribbin
good to be a team effort here to lift it
I think there we go
that is awesome
and I'm sure George will get it and
let's not forget the training staff of
all all the teams in a National Hockey
League
medical equipment the lifeline of the
hockey player and assistant coach John
Stevens his third
Stanley Cup two of La now
his first with the Vegas golden knights
but the training staff the lifeline of a
hockey player and
the guys will tell you
very huge part
of the team concept of
winning
the most overworked
and underpaid play people within the
organization
is Sean Burke long time NHL goaltender
golden coach who talked about the fact
that they used five goaltenders during
the regular season
when I saw him halfway through the
season
and they were working there I asked them
are you next
that's how deep it was down
let's not forget the scouts the pro
Scouts the amateur Scouts the
organization win that will be never ever
forgotten
[Music]
on the right the crowd outside they
continue to celebrate
[Music]
back down to the ice Jackie with Aiden
Hill Aidan Hill congratulations can you
believe it
[Laughter]
short answer no no
it's crazy surreal as it should be you
know you've jumped at this moment your
whole life you come in halfway through
this postseason Run for the golden
knights uh how does reality compare to
the dream
I said I don't know you dream about it
every day grow up as crowd so yeah to be
here with this group of guys in this
city in this building it's oh it's a
dream come true
the way the guys block shots in front of
you in this series because they were
just getting in front of everything yeah
no it's our commitment to blocking shots
all year I mean I heard of our
commitment to the defensive Zone has
been unbelievable all season and it paid
off you know you always seem s cool and
Collective Jonathan Marsha solo told me
the other day when he goes five hole on
you in practice you don't like it so
much you care to respond
[Music]
we'll figure that out later but uh
uh he's an awesome guy I love him to
death all right congratulations go
celebrate with your team yeah thank you
thanks
send it over to Darren Payne Bruce
Cassidy Jackie thank you very much what
What feelings are going through you
Butchy well listen it's very rewarding
but I'm in the club now I'm in the club
and I can't kick you out right so that's
the way I'm feeling right now I mean
you've gone through the trials and
tribulations you're hired a year ago
tomorrow and you would have Stanley Cup
here with these guys how special is it
with this group of guys and just really
winning it after you know obviously not
winning in 19. yeah listen it's a great
story very very grateful to get another
opportunity to do it great group of guys
thankful to George and Bill and Kelly
for bringing me on board I'm just here
to do my job and it worked out well so
I'll tell you it's an unbelievable
feeling look at this 20 000 people in
here never forget it never forget it the
family here comes here and I hope they
get out in the ice and hey they're with
you every step of the way and there's
been some ups and downs along the way so
I'm happy for them too they've been
they've been awesome they went to
Florida and you know they're there to
support their dad and can't thank Julian
also awesome congrats
thank you
foreign